This is so annoying that I even have to do
this next segment, but I want to just do it
and get it on the record so that every time
people ask me, did you see what Sam Cedar
or Anna cast sparing or whoever said about
you, David, we can hopefully short circuit
a lot of those conversations.
It's become really trendy for some of the
progressive media audience to go around effectively
tattle tailing to other shows and getting
them to react to what other people are saying
and then playing that back off of the original
host or off of some other person.
So I'll give you an example of how this nonsense
works.
I say something, someone calls into Sam Cedar,
and so Sam did, did you see what David Pakman
said?
Then they take Sam's reaction to something
that by the way, Sam has not seen.
And then they go to some third host and they
say, hey, did you see what Sam Cedar said
about what David Pakman said?
And then they call into my show 10 days later
and they say, David, did you see what so and
so said about what so and so said about what
you said now 10 or 14 days ago.
But the real problem is not the tattling.
Like, okay, it's fine.
There's this kind of progressive media, uh,
um, uh, environment where a lot of the hosts
are in touch and we're sort of sharing an
audience to some degree.
The problem is that people are misquoting
me endlessly and wasting everybody's time.
And I'm going to play an example for you here.
Okay.
I was on the Joe Rogan program in Los Angeles
last week.
In that interview I said that the left needs
to be careful about defining itself too narrowly
and starting to exclude ideas or people that
are reasonable ideas or reasonable people.
I gave the example of different ways of getting
healthcare for everybody and I pointed out
that expanding Medicare to include everyone
in a medicare for all system is one idea and
it's a good idea, but that there are lots
of other ideas that I'm open to.
These all would be systems of universal coverage.
Many are single payer, but my point was it
could look more like Canada.
It could look more like the UK or France or
Germany.
Although I don't think that the Singapore
system is exactly the best path forward.
There are elements of the Singapore system
that are interesting, but my point was all
of these systems are better than ours.
Let's not shut out good ideas or exclude people
who have other ways to get to real universal
total health coverage for anybody.
So what color went to Sam Cedar?
Completely misstated my position as being
for a public option, which is like the softest,
most right wing modification we could make
to the system.
We have an ask Sam Cedar to react to that,
which of course is not what I actually said.
This is a waste of time.
Now, of course, Sam said, I don't know what
David said, but more importantly now, Sam
is responding to something I never actually
said and we all lose when this happens.
We're fighting ideas that I didn't even put
forward.
Let's take a look at it.
Hey Sam, this is nick from CEO.
Nick, what's on your mind?
All right.
Uh, just on the David Pakman Joe Rogan thing.
Uh, so David's pacman's and overall good comms
here.
I don't have a lot of those most I mostly
agree with.
So there were some pretty terrible takes on
tail on Omar that I have trouble getting over.
Oh, okay.
Regardless with Joe,
let's actually stop there.
Just briefly there.
Another example, my terrible takes on Ilhan
Omar, where I called her antisemitic a is
typically the way this goes, which I never
did.
I must have said 25 times now.
I did not say Ilana is antisemitic.
I did not say that.
What Elon Omar said is inherently antisemitic.
I said merely there are many examples of this
same historically antisemitic trope of Jewish
conspiracy to control and what ill on Omar
said referred to that period.
Okay.
That's it.
I didn't say she was antisemitic.
I didn't say what she said is antisemitic
period.
And yet endlessly I'm having to respond to
critiques for things I didn't say.
But let's not go to that one because we have
a different one that we're dealing with.
So let's get back to the Sam Cedar show.
Uh, but anyways, regardless with Joe Rogan,
he made a concession that the left is too
absolute.
Specifically on the topic of Medicare for
all a, I want to hear what you guys think
of this.
Take a, it seems like he's open to the type
of plan.
Liz Warren has also been flirting with a,
as she all steps with from Medicare for all
on notes.
You guys think of that?
Um, characterize that plan.
Cause mean I hadn't, I didn't know what did,
what did pacman say?
I think he's open.
He's open to the public option, things like
that.
He says that the left is too absolute about
wanting just medicare for all.
If he thinks that there's other plans that
we can go with.
Uh, in regards to solving the medicare issue.
I mean, I don't, I'm not even going to play
Sam's response because I didn't say what the
caller wants Sam to react to.
I've not stepped away from Medicare for all.
I haven't said that.
What I want is a public option, which is so
lame.
I've not said any of it.
What's the point in getting Sam to react to
something?
I didn't say.
I've been at the forefront of this issue on
health care for a decade.
For as long as I've been doing the show, there's
no upside to the movement to going to Sam
Cedar and getting him to react to a position
that is not mine.
Single payer doesn't have to mean medicare
for all.
When you look at all the systems that are
better than ours, whether it's Canada or the
UK, Netherlands, Switzerland, Germany, France,
whatever.
They aren't all single payer.
Many of them are, but in all of them, the
government plays a major role as both a regulator
and a funder through taxation.
The private sector often still exists to different
degrees.
Some places you still have private insurance
as an option that's available if you want
it to.
Different degrees.
Private industry is still running hospitals
or some clinics or whatever.
Everybody has to have coverage no matter what
system they have.
You need that to have the largest possible
risk pool.
You could argue that the German system might
more easily build on what we have in a more
immediate way.
That would be a respectable position.
The French system is great, but 90% of the
population has something beyond the national
system is what elements of that might make
sense in any case.
The point is we are wasting time when we do
this.
When I say a and a color goes to Sam and to
Sam.
David Pakman said, be react to it.
And Sam says, well, based on B, I think, see
I never said be okay.
So C is pointless.
It's a waste of time.
Let's stop doing it.
Okay, let's stop the tattling.
Let's actually work productively here to improve
our country, to improve the society around
us and not waste anybody's time with this
nonsense.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram at David Pakman show.
While you're there, follow me on Instagram
at David Dot.
Pacman, lots of behind the scenes pictures
and memes and all sorts of stuff from my trip
to Los Angeles last week during which I appeared
on the Joe Rogan program and interview that
now it's actually doing really well.
It has surpassed a ton of these MMA folks
that Joe Rogan sometimes interviews and even
some of the political folks and only the first
five days, I think a 1.2 million views now
for the main Joe Rogan interview, which was
two hours.
So make sure you walk
shit, keep sharing.
Keep refreshing cause we want to get those
numbers up as high as possible and uh, more
exciting announcements by the way, coming
up very soon.